لحظات من الراحه ياخذها هؤلاء الجنود
الاوكرانيون قبل العوده الى جبهه القتال
في مدينه باخموت شرق البلاد نجحت القوات
الاوكرانيه لحد الساعه في سد اكثر من 100
هجوم للقوات الروسيه في الساعات الاخيره
بينما تسيطر مجموعه فاجنر الخاصه على
ثلاثه مداخل من اصل اربعه لمدينه ضخمه
الاستراتيجيه
لا اعلم ما الذي سيحدث غدا او حتى الليله
الوضع يتغير كل دقيقه
يمكن ان نقصف الان لا احد يعلم ماذا سيحدث
غدا على كل سنرى
يتزايد الرهان بين كييف وموسكو حول صمود
المدينه فيما ظهر قائد مجموعه باغ داني
بريكوجين في مقطع فيديو وخلفهما قال انها
جثه مقاتلين اوكرانيين سقطوا في المعارك
الميدانيه
نرسل شحنه اخرى من مقاتليها الجيش
الاوكراني الى الوطن
قتلوا بشجاعه قبل ان يسقطوا
لهذا السبب ستعيدهما الشاحنه الى وطنهم
الام
ايضا رئيس الاوكراني الى سحب ما تبقى من
قواته في بخموت قبل ان تنشر موسكو مقطع
فيديو يظهر وزير الدفاع الروسي وهو يتفقد
مركز قياده على الجبهه في اتجاه دونيتسك
دون تحديد الموقع او تاريخ الزياره